[Music]
in our series world of weddings we're
traveling all around the world to see
unique ceremonies and understand what
marriage means in different countries in
the u.s. many couples chooses you know
large weddings and that comes with big
expectations and big big budgets a lot
of money now some are taking a very
different approach Adriana Diaz met one
couple in Ohio who decided to go tiny on
their big day hello newlywed mrs. Smith
also known as Adriana dia hello gale so
yesterday as you remember we showed you
an arranged Indian wedding that's a
practice that goes back centuries this
morning we're introducing you to a
couple that met the modern American Way
online they're also bucking other
traditions to make the wedding work for
them and their budget and awarding to
viewers this couple is very cute it was
instant chemistry she just got me this
Ohio pair is so compatible even their
names are a perfect match
meet Sean and fawn how did you guys meet
Anton reisender I think this guy's not
gonna match with me but like whatever
I'm confident I could do this I'm like
this lady is going to be getting her
doctor it's like what data analyst vodka
plan DS and student Sean Stevens bonded
over camping and outdoor sports
I think the second date you told me you
loved me yes I saw the Sun and it was
reflecting off of her hair I could
imagine growing old with this person and
all the sappy stuff that men don't want
to admit but you know I wear my heart on
my sleeve and I just said you know let's
just give it all you got so
first came love then came marriage
proposal then came a long wait so like
okay well it'll be like five years so we
get married that's right they considered
waiting five years to save sixty
thousand dollars to wet at their dream
venue Zingerman's corn man farms in
nearby Michigan
the u.s. is one of the most expensive
places to get married on average last
year couples tied the knot spent more
than $1,600 on the dress just over $500
on cake and more than 2400 on flowers in
all the average cost for a wedding in
2018 was nearly $34,000 you're also
taught that it has to be big you have to
invite everyone and you have to have the
alcohol tap
but then another path down the aisle
popped up on her Instagram feed they
started posting about tiny weddings like
okay we could do this the posts were
from her ideal venue corn man farms
so Jonah possibly one of the picnic
baskets for this year owner and chef
Kieran Hales is trying something new so
we have one two three four five six
seven eight chairs here that's it it's
maxed out that sure is tiny yeah it is a
tiny wedding they're tiny wedding
package is a bite-sized version of the
lavish parties here that range from
$17,000 to 250 thousand dollars but with
eight guests max a tiny wedding costs
one thousand nine hundred and fifty
dollars that's because the 90-minute
celebrations of vows cake and champagne
are stacked back to back with the same
officiant decorations and photographer
are you seeing fewer people that want to
do the big traditional wedding I think
that it's not fewer I just think that
now we're seeing maybe the newer
generation of those guests getting
married now in like their 20s and 30s
are definitely moving more to our
intimate style
I think that that group of people is a
group of people that as far as the
wedding industry we've underserved and
now he's serving them where they are
their phones where an entire tiny
wedding can be planned in seconds you
select date this is crazy time about
nice yep 32 cards yep check out dumb
this is how I order like toiletries to
have everything done and pulled together
for me it's super easy it's incredible
that it's just like one-click wedding
planning yes in all they spend eight
thousand dollars including the dress tux
and party favors the venue just had them
picked their cake flavor
music by their rings wedding ready
wedding ready
[Music]
she came around the corner and I was
just taken aback I absolutely am happy
that we went this route we can now buy a
house and then I can get my dog PhD
puppies we like to call-- yes
but I think that is very American that
we can put our own twist on it we can
build this wedding that we really want
and it's okay if we only have eight
other people there
if you're with the person that you love
you share that moment with them that's
all that matters
that is all that matters so we checked
in with our couple they have yet to get
any PhD puppies but they are looking to
buy a house and with all the money that
they saved on the wedding we'll have
more to spend on the house and to
kick-start their life - I'm glad you
gave us a warning when you said super
cute cute starting with their names
Shaun and fawn and I love Shaun saying
she just got me may we all have one of
those you already have that mrs. Minh I
keep calling her mrs. Smith because
she's a newlywed
you got married this summer I did Gayle
and we just heine wedding was it a tug
this is your first year this is not a
tiny way it's a song of your first oh my
gosh this is our first dance yeah this
is Sunday kind of love
the dress is beautiful Hawaii thank you
doctor looks good two hundred people
they're not so tiny we were actually
inspired by our Indian friends who've
had big extravaganza so we had a
three-day affair yeah it was nice
does he get you he gets me did he cry no
Oh soon enough
he still gets yeah yeah all right thank
you so much